The trick here was to identify the pattern. If we look at the total number of
wiper blades that have been made at the end of any one of the days on this
table, and then we look at how many have been made by the end of the next day,
that is where we see the pattern. After the first day, there are 23, but after
the second day, there are 46. The difference between 46 and 23 is 23.
To get from 46 to 69, we have to add 23 again. And we do the same thing to get
from 69 to 92. So, you can see that as each day goes by, we're adding 23 wiper
blade sets to the total number of wiper blade sets that have been made. So,
logically, we do that again when we move from day 4 to day 5. This means we need
to add 23 to 92 to get the number that belongs in the teal box. 92 plus 23 is
115. At the end of day 5, 115 wiper blade sets will have been produced in total.